leben wo gar kein leben möglich ist der
mysteriöse schwarze pilz gedeiht mitten
in den tschernobyl ruinen und ernährt
sich nicht nur von der
lebensgefährlichen gammastrahlung
sondern wandelt diese sogar in energie
um
jetzt wurde dieser pilz auf der
internationalen raumstation iss
gezüchtet könnte dieser strahlen fresse
möglicherweise raumschiffe und deren
crew vor der gefährlichen kosmischen
strahlung schützen und vielleicht auch
krebs erkrankte bei der strahlentherapie
unterstützen klicks und science fiction
er gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen der
mysteriöse schwarze pilz wurde bereits
fünf jahre nach der reaktorkatastrophe
tschernobyl im inneren der ruinen
entdeckt also wo eigentlich gar nichts
überleben kann
es ist wirklich absolut erstaunlich wie
sich dieser pilz gerade an diesem ort an
diesem super lebensfeindlichen ort
eingenistet hat denn er ernährt sich
nicht nur von der tödlichen
gammastrahlung sondern kann diese sogar
in energie umsetzen
dies hatte schon ein experiment im jahr
2010 gezeigt irgendwo es forschungsteam
hatte damals verschiedene pilzarten
einer strahlendosis ausgesetzt die 500
mal höher war als die natürliche
strahlung der erde und das ergebnis war
eindeutig alle pilzarten die melanin
enthielten wuchsen dadurch schneller als
ohne zusätzliche radioaktivität oder
anders formuliert je höher die strahlung
ist umso schneller wachsen die pilze
melanin ist übrigens der farbstoff der
bei uns menschen für die färbung der
haut und haare verantwortlich ist die
damaligen experimente legten also schon
nahe
das melanin die pilze dazu befähigt
radioaktive strahlung in einer
energieform umzuwandeln
die diese dann wiederum für ihren
stoffwechsel gebrauchen können dieser
mechanismus ist tatsächlich vergleichbar
mit der photosynthese bei der pflanzen
ja aus sonnenlicht energie gewinnen
deswegen ist auch von radio synthese die
rede mittlerweile geht man davon aus
dass es bis zu 200 verschiedene
pilzarten gibt die innerhalb der
tschernobyl ruinen leben die nasa hat
diese strahlungs resistenten pilze ganz
genau im visier ganz vorne mit dabei der
nasa mitarbeiter cuturi
diese waren nach dem unfall waren pilze
die ersten organismen die dort
auftauchten und die wissenschaftler
wollten verstehen wie sie in einer
solchen umgebung den sein können seine
experimente haben gezeigt dass die pilze
die sich weit innen im kernkraftwerk
aufhalten deutlich dunkler sind als
diejenigen die weiter außen zu finden
sind
der experte ist deswegen davon überzeugt
dass der pilz sich anpasst und die
strahlung zitat liebt ein fünftel der
pilzarten geht sogar so weit sich in
richtung der strahlung zu orientieren
sie wachsen quasi in die
strahlungsquelle hinein ganz so als
würden sie nach nahrung greifen wie
pflanzen die in richtung des
sonnenlichts wachsen dazu castor
event.at sie war an die pilze dem
reaktor gesammelt worden hatten mehr
melanin als die pilze die außerhalb in
der sperrzone gesammelt wurden das
bedeutet dass sich die pilze an die
strahlungs aktivität angepasst haben und
sie sogar der strahlung entgegen wachsen
sie lieben sie die nasa hatte die pilze
im juli des vergangenen jahres 2009 10
mit hilfe einer space extrakte zur
internationalen raumstation iss
geschickt um dort noch mehr über sie zu
erfahren
die große hoffnung kann man die
schwarzen pilze nutzen um raumschiffe
oder sogar menschen vor der gefährlichen
kosmischen strahlung zu schützen
denn klar ist im weltall ist die
strahlung deutlich höher als auf der
erde und kein raum schrift dieser welt
kann diese gefährliche strahlung so gut
abhalten wie es die atmosphäre die
ozonschicht und das magnetfeld der erde
es tun
auf der iss ist das weniger ein problem
weil das erdmagnetfeld einiges davon
bereits weiter außen abhält bei
zukünftigen mars missionen aber würde
die besatzung eine große strahlendosis
abbekommen
und fest steht sie kann das menschliche
gewebe und nervenzellen tatsächlich
schädigen dass sie die aluminiumhülle
des raumschiffes durch trinkt
forschungsteams befürchten dass die
strahlung direkt auch auswirkungen auf
die insassen haben könnte beispielsweise
könnten die emotionale stabilität und
die reaktionsfähigkeit nachlassen aber
auch das krebsrisiko steigt durch die
strahlung forschungsteams weltweit sind
dabei medikamente zu entwickeln die
wirkung der kosmischen strahlung
abfedern könnten beispielsweise in dem
die menschlichen zellen strahlen
resistenter gemacht werden doch
möglicherweise lässt sich ja auch der
schwarze pilz gezielt züchten
so dass man ihn zur dämmung radioaktiver
strahlung einsetzen kann die bisherige
forschung auf der ss jedenfalls legt
nahe dass der pilz enorm anpassungsfähig
ist und sich unter stress verändert
weitere ergebnisse dazu sollen demnächst
in einer großen studie veröffentlicht
werden bisher ist jedenfalls klar der
stromfresser ließe sich nicht nur
hervorragend in der raumfahrt einsetzen
auch in der medizin könnte er sich als
nützlich erweisen beispielsweise indem
man krebs patientinnen und patienten bei
einer strahlentherapie schützt und die
visionen der fachwelt sind groß
zumindest in der theorie wäre auch
denkbar dass man ihn einsetzen könnte um
auf radioaktivität bio strom zu erzeugen
sabotage auf der internationalen
raumstation iss anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren und zwar kriegs um
science-fiction bis dann bleibt dran